je trouve très frais je ne trouve
qu'elles vivent 1 et ma foi je vous
regarde et je vous trouve très jeune
nous revenons de loin mais nous irons
encore plus loin
permettez moi d'adresser d'abord
quelqu'un remerciements dans quelques
heures il y aura 21 ans que mon père
nous a quittés j'ai une pensée pour son
doigt vindicatif et son admiration pour
les vaincre permettez moi de remercier
nancy et les enfants pour leur patience
et beaucoup mieux pour leurs
encouragements et leur regard qui brille
au meilleur moment
je veux remercier les militantes et les
militants de beloeil chambly les
électeurs de beloeil shamblin vous
m'avez accueilli avec une chaleur ma foi
piano delà de mes espérances
je veux
[Applaudissements]
je veux je veux saluer toutes les
militantes et tous les militants du bloc
québécois
je veux aussi remercier mon conseiller
et annie et inspiration
monsieur gilles duceppe ce monsieur je
dis c'est bien d'ailleurs de confier au
bloc québécois son fils largement élu
dans lac saint jean
[Applaudissements]
je
on la casse pour la trace indélébile qui
leur a laissé dans l'histoire du québec
je veux aussi remercier lucie bouchard g
j'ai pensé tout amicale mais surtout
reconnaissante pour une équipe une
petite équipe mais une équipe qui a
réalisé une campagne
impossible en ressources et en
ressources humaines en argent nous avons
fait plus que beaucoup avec moins que
tous va voir à bien des égards ce fut
une campagne victorieuse
[Applaudissements]
je gardais pour la fais mes amis
candidates et candidats
quel courage des sceaux aujourd'hui avec
le recul
vu de loin on peut se dire que c'est un
choix qui aurait pu avoir l'air un peu
facile mais réalisée il ya quatre ans il
ya six mois quand on était encore des
fous il ya des fous qui ont dit oui et
qui s'en viennent à la chambre des
communes
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup merci ses gens nous
ont mis une vie professionnelle de côté
et ils ont gagné une obligation solennel
à l'endroit des québécois mais plusieurs
dont certains que j'ai vu ici ce soir
n'ont pas été choisis vous en tirez une
reconnaissance vibrante de beaucoup de
québécois et vous avez non seulement ma
reconnaissance
mais vous avez mon amitié durable
les québécois et les canadiens se donne
ce soir un parlement minoritaire
aucun parti parmi ceux qui aspirent
aspirait n'a obtenu une majorité de
sièges
aucun parti ce soir ne prend le contrôle
de la chambre des communes
au québec le bloc québécois ne veut pas
former un gouvernement ni même participé
à un gouvernement
en revanche le bloc québécois peut on
milite collaborer avec n'importe quel
gouvernement
si si ce qui est proposé est bon pour le
québec
vous pourrez compter sur nous si ce qui
est mis de l'avant et nuisible pour le
québec le bloc se dressera sur le chemin
si le gouvernement et par la bhl il est
temps le tempérament même des québécois
d'être par la bhl alors le bloc
québécois sera par la bhl sauf sauf s'il
s'agit de passer davantage de pétrole à
travers le québec
sauf s'il s'agit de renoncer ou
compromettre des valeurs notre langue ou
l'engagement du québec envers la laïcité
des institutions publiques
je ne crois pas que les québécois et les
canadiens était lui un gouvernement
minoritaire dans le but de retourner aux
urnes dans 18 mois ou dans deux ans et
demi je crois que les québécois et les
canadiens nous demandent tous partis et
toutes régions confondues
malgré les divisions profondes qui
marque la carte politique du canada
aujourd'hui il nous demande de
travailler ensemble ils nous demandent
de faire marcher un état bien n'est
parfait un pays qui fait peu de cas
depuis 37 ans de laisser de côté près du
quart de sa population dans une
constitution à laquelle ils n'ont jamais
adhéré
mais
c'est un parlement que nous devrons
faire fonctionner le bloc québécois
prend toute la mesure du mandat qui lui
est confié
dans ce contexte nous avons proposé
d'être la voix d'une nation québécoise
qui s'est retrouvée qui s'est retrouvé
dans son seul parlement national
l'assemblée nationale du québec nous
sommes la voix des consensus de
l'assemblée nationale du québec
nous nous sommes solennellement engagé à
porter sous mandat l'entièreté de ce
mandat en toute conscience et sans
équivoque
nous saisissons toute la portée du
mandat mais aussi ses limites
les membres les militants et les
électeurs du bloc québécois tous savent
que nous croyons qu'un jour le plus vite
possible mais à son moment et à sa
manière le québec pourrait choisir de se
doter de tous les attributs de la
souveraineté
[Applaudissements]
mais j'ai eu
et à
moi aussi
mais j'ai une admiration sans bornes
un respect une reconnaissance
responsable envers nos militants nos
gens d'une nature parfois peu patientes
mais pour tous ces gens mes amis tous
ces gens qui acceptent que le québec
avait besoin que pour cette fois
pour cette fois la réalisation de la
souveraineté ne soit pas notre mandat
en effet
[Applaudissements]